Hello again. Today we're going to talk about phase angles and cancer. Most people don't know
what a phase angle is at all. They think we're talking about geometry, but we're not talking
about geometry. We're talking about a measurement that you can measure in a clinic to measure the
health of a cell membrane. So let's jump right into this and talk about what a phase angle is.
Well, a phase angle is a ratio between the reactants and the resistance.
Big words as you don't understand when you're talking about what are we measuring? What's the
reactants and the resistance? Well, really two little electrodes are placed on the feet and two
on the hands. And this machine puts a little teeny measure of resistance, a little teeny
electrode through the skin. You can't even feel it. And it measures the reactants and resistance
of that electrode from the hand down to the foot. And by putting it into a computer program,
it gives us what's called the bioelectrical impedance. So that's what a phase angle is is your cell
impedance. So it's really measuring in short the health of the cell membrane. So all your cells
are have a wall around them. That's what we call them with plants. We call them cell walls with
animals, humans. We call them cell membranes. That membrane is made up of a phospholipid
bilayer. That's for a phosphorous group and a lipid that's attached, a phosphorous group attached
to the end of a low lipid. And it's a bilayer. We need it there. They're set. There's two layers
of this phospholipid. So it's actually a hydrophilic and a hydrophobic. And we won't get too much into
that. But that's the cell membrane. The cell membrane has all these different receptors in it.
It goes three dimensionally around the cell. And then in the cell is the cytoplasm. And the cytoplasm
is kind of a gelatinous water. It's water in a certain state that makes it gelatinous. And that's
where all the organelles, organelles are little T organs inside the cell that do all sorts of
things. You have thousands of mitochondria, lysosomes, all sorts of ribosomes, all sorts of different
things. And in the center, that cell is nucleus. So that's what is a cell. And that's what the health
of our body is, is the health of our cells. So if our cells go rogue and start replicating rapidly,
that's what's called cancer. We want to measure the cell membrane integrity. It's not
measuring any specific organ. It's just measuring a general cell membrane integrity. That's what a
phase angle is. So it doesn't make a difference what type of cancer, what type of disease you have.
It's just giving us a number. So that's what we're measuring with this number.
So what is a normal phase angle? Well, phase angle will really be measured from 0 to about 11,
11.5. The younger you are, the higher phase angle you will have. The highest I think we've ever
had with somebody was I think 10 something, 10 points something I can't remember. I used to treat
some of the Minnesota Vikings players. They're at the prime of their health and they would be in the
eats nines. But really someone who's nine years old would have a higher phase angle. They're healthier.
They have picked up less toxins so far in their life. And that's the biggest thing that that decreases
a person's phase angle is the health of their cell membrane or the ill health of the cell membrane.
So what causes ill health of the cell membrane? Well, all sorts of things can can get
embedded in the cell membrane that are unhealthy. That's the bad thing about trans fats. These
large fats, long chain fats that they can actually get embedded and actually transpose your
phospholipid bilayer. And the trans fats actually can technically like plasticize your cell membranes.
And then there's no room for the receptors that need to actually turn things on and off and allow
things to get inside the cell and allow, you know, that's a big part of apoptosis is receptor
health. So all sorts of different things lower our phase angle. Age will lower our phase angle. As
we get older, we're going to have a lower phase angle. Even if you do everything to stay healthy,
you can still have a lower phase angle. Exposure to toxins, exposure to poisons, unhealthy lifestyle,
bad choices in food, etc., can lower our phase angle. Disease will lower our phase angle. Cancer
patients can have a phase angle anywhere really between 4 and 6.5. But we really want to see our
cancer patients when we start with them on our day, our today intensive to have a phase angle of 5.5
or greater. That would be best. We've had people in the twos before, people in the threes,
they're going to be less healthy people. So it's just where you are, is where you are. It's like,
okay, well, we got work to do and we got to get this person healthier. What we really look for
on a phase angle with a cancer patient is how it's moving. And I realize when we see somebody from
Florida on a two day, they never come back up here to get those that measured. Again, we can't
even measure it again. But you can't find another clinic that will measure a phase angle. That's
where a lot of the studies are with cancer is which direction is that phase angle going throughout
care. So a low phase angle may suggest deterioration or loss of healthy charge of that cell membrane
like we spoke of. And a low phase angle can show that the cancer is advancing and the overall
survival is going to be reduced at a cancer patient if their if their phase angle is dropping.
So if a person comes into their phase angle 6.0 and they're undergoing chemotherapy and chemotherapy
is probably one of the, you know, most toxic things that damage your phase angle, okay, what are your
damaging? Your damaging the cell health, the cell membrane health. So if you are doing chemotherapy,
then you can definitely damage the cell membrane and you can drop the phase angle.
Matter of fact, there's numerous studies that are most the studies that are done with phase angle
are done with cancer patients. That's really what really put phase angle on the map. And if a person's
phase angle is dropping rapidly, it's not a good sign. So it's again measuring cell membrane integrity.
So how can I improve my phase angle? What can I do to get my phase angle up? It was only, you know,
4.5. What I started, what can I do to get it up? Well, everything that you're doing, everything that we
put you on as far as your program is designed to increase your phase angle. Why did you tell me that
before? Because that's not important. It's designed to get you better. And if your phase angle goes
up, you're going to get you're getting better. So phase angle is a measurement of are you getting better
or are you not getting better? Literally. So it gets a cell membrane health is the phase angle. So
detoxification is very important. So detoxing from the cell membrane, getting rid of the the fats that
are embedded in the cell membrane, the unhealthy fats, the toxins, the heavy metals that are embedded
in the cell membrane is very important. So detoxification is really key to improving cell membrane.
Generally improving overall health, your diet, your nutrition, your outlook on life, your
attitude, all those things are going to improve the health of the cell membrane.
And then increasing healthy fats, this is a phospholipid bilayer. So increasing healthy fats is
going to help with the cell membrane. But by doing this just by itself without doing other things,
this is probably going to budge the phase angle at all. But the healthy fats that you want to improve
with to help your cell membranes is phosphatidal colline. That's the PC bio here. That's the
phosphatidal colline. That's direct piece that fits into your cell membrane. And PEOs,
paratessential oils. This is the this product is the fatty acid the quesadis. So fatty acids in the
quesadis are paratessential oils that are good fats for your cell membranes. Omega-3s could break out
to be beneficial for cell membranes too. So good fats, eating good foods, eating fish,
that salmon that has good omega-3s and good paratessential oils at it are good things to add to
help improve your cell membrane. The rife is a key component to improving cell membrane.
Because that's what's adding charge to your cell membrane directly. The PE OFF is also,
so I listed that as well. So but the rife is adding charge to the cell based upon the frequency
of the cell itself. So when we're hitting your liver cells with the rife, we're bringing
resident back to that cell that's doing wonders to help improve the cell membrane and the charge
of the cell membrane. Because that's really again what we're measuring. And yes, the PE OFF,
somebody asked a question is a great thing to help improve the cell membrane too. So you're just
adding charge to the cell, adding charge to the cell membrane, the health of the cell membrane
equals the health of the person. And you will see that directly study after study shows that as a
person cell, our phase angle drops, it's a picture of their overall health. So if a person's
phase angle is plummetied, their overall health is plummetied. And it's not a good outcome usually
with that. So we want to do everything we can. So everything that we are doing for you is aimed at
improving the health of your cells. And when we say we're improving the health of your cells, we're
talking about, we could measure it with the phase angle. All right. Now I'm going to unmute you.
And you can ask questions. Somebody did ask a question about coconut oil.
Coconut oil is what I would consider a pair to essential oil. It's some definitions of the term.
So coconut oil is a good fact to use. Is a higher power,
rife system, an advantage to improving phase angle in cell health? No, I would not say so.
It's a frequency that you're using with the rife, not the power that you're using.
So I will say that even our power PEMF units could be beneficial in this case too. So
when you're at the office, we have the pulse machine, which is a high power or the high power PEMF,
the high power high frequency PEMF. But we also have the sequence, which is a low power low frequency
PEMF. The sequence is just as helpful as far as improving the charge of the cell membrane right
as the pulse is. So have that advantage. So if you have a lower power PEMF like a beaver or
high of arrests you get home or what of our home units that could be just as beneficial as far as
cell membrane health goes. It just has some shortcomings as far as like inflammation goes.
Okay. We'll open it up to questions. One other question. So somebody asked, can we test phase angle
at home? If you have the RJL machine that we have, yes, you could. I actually had a patient that
had a pink eradic cancer a number of years ago that she bought that machine so he could measure his
phase angle. They're not real cheap. So they're no, he's the only person I've ever known that spot one.
So most clinics don't have them. I know the cancer treatment centers of America has them. They use
them all the time. Again, most of the studies are with cancer patients. So your, you know, most
cancer patients, clinics, most non-cancer clinics are not going to have tool to measure the phase angle.
Okay. Any questions? Dr. Connors, how often would you measure a phase angle?
Well, the phase angle isn't going to budge very quickly. So it's not something like,
oh, I ate really good this week. Could I measure it? Oh, it went up two points.
Oh, I ate really bad. I know I dropped two points. It's not going to work that way.
So there's no real need to measure the phase angle more than maybe once every corner,
maximum. It's really not going to budge that quickly. So if a person just, you know, completely
changed their whole lifestyle and their diet. No, they're using it a rife and they're doing a
sauna and they're helping detox and they're, you know, eat, change their diet completely eating
correctly and unreally good nutrition. They're using their rife. They could have changes in three
months. But let's say they were at a 5.3 when they came here, it might go up to 5.5.
We've had it jump faster than that with some people, but it's been rare. We've had it fall
faster than that with some people. But that's not real comedy either. And that's usually if a person's,
where we've really seen it really plummet is if a person goes back and does chemo
they just their whole health, you know, plummets as well. And you could measure it out of phase
angle. And you can see it's pretty long. So. Dr. Connors, this is Tomahai. I was wondering,
I don't know that ever got done since I'm a, I'm not there on your area. Exactly. So I don't
know that ever got done on me, but is there, do you have resources where I could go here and
and say, Lewis maybe? Or we could look up St. Louis. Let me, let me do a little research. I know
somebody in St. Louis area. Okay. Let me do a little research on that. Oh. Okay. Great.
Dr. Connors? Yes. How do we, I don't remember what mine was. This is Giana. I don't remember
when I was out there. I don't remember where it was at or anything. Is there a way to find that out?
Yeah. It's on your chart. So we can email it to you. Okay. Yeah. Thank you.
Absolutely. So you could ask questions outside of this. What other questions does anybody have?
Maybe not pertaining to phase angle? I had another question. I was reading about a lady using
molecular hydrogen to cure her breast cancer or whatever. Have you any thoughts or opinions on
or inhaling it? Yeah. So hydrogen water, molecular hydrogen,
and hydrogen tablets used in water to increase the hydrogen content of the water
have been big. And kind of hot topics in the nutritional world in the last couple of years.
There's pros and cons that you have to be aware of. So if a person has specific genetic defects
when the girls go over a person's genetic profile, that may be something that they
recommend. So there can be benefits to hydrogen in that sense based upon a person's genetic profile.
Number two, there can be benefits to grab reactive oxygen and reactive nitrogen species,
especially in the gut if we think that that's going out. And that's usually if there's
high amount of toxins in the gut. Not biotoxins, but inert toxins. So biotoxid is a livid organism.
An inert toxic is, let's say the person has a mercury toxicity or something that's some other
heavy metal toxic or glyphosate toxicity that it's really affecting the gut badly. That's where
molecular hydrogen can really shine. The danger of molecular hydrogen is if a person has a biotoxin.
So if a person has biotoxin, like H. Pylori, then actually molecular hydrogen can make the problem
works. And there's several research articles that came out of that and I'd have to pull them up and
we could do a zoo call about it if we wanted to. But the bottom line is if you have a biotoxid
of the gut, Lyme disease, H. Pylori is what most studies were done on, then molecular hydrogen actually
makes the problem worse and actually feeds the H. Pylori can make it grow more. Now the problem,
but that is what H. Pylori, I don't have H. Pylori. Well, the truth is probably 80% of the population
have H. Pylori over growth to some degree. H. Pylori is helicobacter pylori. It's a grand
negative bacteria. It is the cause of stomach ulcers, but it could go intracellular and into the blood
stream. It is one of the top five causes of coronary heart disease. Coronary heart disease, according to
the research right now, is still the number one cause of death in the United States.
In H. Pylori is, according to all the research, one of the top five causes of coronary heart disease.
So that's how prevalent H. Pylori is. H. Pylori is the number one cause of stomach cancer,
according to the World Health Organization, worldwide. H. Pylori is very prevalent.
Personally, that's why I'm really high on burmarine. So I personally take burmarine at least three
times a week because it's really good for cancer. Number one, burmarine can really be a great
cancer killer, but burmarine is the key H. Pylori killer. And my dad had a heart attack at 57 years old,
added up diet of heart disease and kidney disease because he never took care of himself,
and I had ulcer issues. I know he had H. Pylori issues. So if you have heart disease in your family,
you probably got H. Pylori in your family. H. Pylori is highly contagious,
better fact, according to the birth manual, you're supposed to treat the person with H. Pylori.
If he doesn't get better or he's reinfected within 30 days, the treatment schedule is that you treat
him and the whole family, including the family pets. So that's how prevalent H. Pylori is.
So that's why we don't use hydrogen water. So it has its benefits as a free radical scavenger,
but it has its negatives as a feeder of H. Pylori and other biotoxins.
Does that help? Yes, thank you. Okay, Dr. Canners, now my brain is going
to get better. Because I am the one who took the microhydrine capsules.
But I explain this to you, and I don't want to probably zoom over your head what I did.
Well, I mean, it's all coming full circle, but you know, I'm still, I mean, just so everyone
else who's on my nose, I mean, almost immediately, I began to have like worms and snakes all through
my intestines, and I called Dr. Canners, and he said, oh boy, you know, you're dealing with H. Pylori.
So I've been taking what you said faithfully, you know, and it's been what, three weeks maybe,
but I am still dealing with some of those issues. So let's bring everybody else up to speed.
You went to a seminar in your area, it heard somebody speak about this product,
that it was a hydrogen product, and you started taking this hydrogen product, and then you got worse.
And then you called me, and I said, well, you probably got H. Pylori, because that's a hydrogen
product, and you're worse after that. That's pretty good sign that that's what it is. So I gave you
the HPLR, I think, which has got burberry and some other things in it, that it was a product by
Apex that was developed just for H. Pylori. And so it's just can take some time. So it's just what
it is. And that's why it's a nasty bacteria that is overgrown. So H. Pylori has several
different species to it. And there are some species that are part of our normal gut biode.
And so it can easily grow out of control without our immune system recognizing it as a bad guy.
So that's the reason why it can become such a nasty thing, because your immune system doesn't
necessarily recognize it as growing out of control because it's normally a part of the bio. So it's easy
to get out, it's easy for it to go crazy. So yeah, you have to stay out. That's why I, again,
that's why I take the vermer clear literally I've taken that stuff for years. And I don't always,
honestly, it'll take it every day. But I take at least three times a week just because I know that
that's so prevalent. And I know that, you know, I have a family history of that. So
now. Okay, go ahead. Go ahead, Janet. All right. So my next question is when they did the genetics
testing, it did show that I had tendencies towards heart disease and strokes. But I chose to not,
I can't remember, it's not in front of me, what the supplement was that was recommended.
But I chose to not take that. Get that right now. And I'm thinking after everything,
you're just saying and me dealing with these issues of Hylori that maybe I should be taking that
after all. I would necessarily say that no. Okay, because I'm doing the verber clear. And then I'm also
on, you know, also taking the HPLR that you told me to take. Yep. So keep up with those. And we
are having these got issues. It's probably still in the gut. So it will, the burberade,
and the other stuff that's in the HPLR will circulate in your bloodstream and help kill it too. So
I wouldn't necessarily, that doesn't really equate to the necessarily heart issues.
Okay. All right. Thank you. Just, uh, this is like so enlightening. And I just want to say thank
you again. I'm just so blessed. I just learned so much. And it's so enlightening to me. And I am
very, very thankful. Well, you're very welcome. I'm glad you actually like to learn. So not
everybody does. Dr. Connor. Yeah. Again. Yeah. I want to, I will also vote for, I love to learn.
And we spoke the other day and we talked about the mercury. I had mercury taken out of my energy
and I was going to talk to him and said, um, I'm cleanse, which I did. And I actually felt
that right away. Oh, good. So I've been doing it. That was, uh, this is going to be tonight. It
will be the third day. And the first day was pretty dark, but the second actually got much better.
Oh, that's good. Yeah. So, um, I guess, um, I wanted to know if, oh, and I went to my, uh,
doctor and he told me that, um, he pulled up some lab tests then. Well, I, um,
monthly ones and all of my, um, labs are really loud, low, including all of them. And see,
everything is the lowest is everything. Can you send me those so I can see what he's talking about?
Yes. I will do that. And what I'm wondering is, you know, is my immune system
hiding mercury coming out of the body? Yeah. It's hard to say that until I see what
numbers are actually low. Yeah. Well, okay. And he's 900. All of them. I usually run low,
it's just much lower this time. Okay. Well, it said me, then we'll talk about it.
Okay. All right. Oh, and one more thing. And you talked about bloating and I said,
that's better, not really. So the bloating is still there? Yeah. It's still there.
All right. So that might correlate to the blood tests. So. Okay. So I'll send you that. All right.
Thank you. You're welcome. Dr. Connors? Yes. Dennis Baldur's here. A couple quick,
choir questions. Since phase angle is measured like you think you said from hand to foot,
does it just measure along the surface? Or does it measure the internally as well?
So it's measured internally. So it's putting a little electrical impulse in
through those little sticky things that are on your skin. Right. Then picking it up out at your
feet and seeing the impedance. So if you had low shit on your skin, you know, going down or you
were just out, subtidied in your head, subtidling a lot or something that wouldn't affect it.
Okay. And do I understand correctly? You said like phase angle then was a good indication of like
overall health. Yeah. Well, it's a really good indication of it. Again, it is a measurement of how
healthy your cells are. So how healthy your cells are are a good indication of overall health.
So my phase angle is 2.5. I quite honestly probably don't have very long to live. So
it's my phase angle is 7.0. So you have stage 4 cancer in your phase angle 7.0. That is fantastic.
You know, the chance that you beat this is pretty dark. So your phase angle is 5.5. Well,
that's okay, but we also don't know what it was before you got cancer. You know, so
it's, you know, we just want to build it up. We what, you know, I always like to see our patients
over 5.5. But you know, we've had patients in the tooth again. So, but that's a good outcome. So
again, it's like, so it's an arbitrary number. How do I know if that's good or not? You know,
well, is there is there some level of genetic predisposition to a healthier phase angle? Well,
sure, just as much as there is a genetic predisposition to somebody living to 105 years old,
they they have just healthier cell membranes. But overall, you could, when you look at your
phase angle, you want it to, you know, stay the same or rise throughout your course of treatment.
It's with it, if it starts to drastically drop is where you start to get a little concerned.
Okay, thank you. All right, any other questions? I know we that some people have said did some other
questions on their emails. And that I did get to them today, I think, myself and Michelle will
probably make some short videos this week or early next week. I have to go speak this weekend at
in Ohio to, I guess there's going to be about 500 people there. I'm talking on cancer and
live to kind of an Amish community there. So I covered your prayers for that. And then next week,
next week, thank you, next week, we'll get, if I don't get those any videos done before that,
we'll get some done next week about those questions. So again, if you have questions that you don't
feel comfortable asking live on the Zoom call, or you can't be on the Zoom call, please
send them to the email. Please put in the subject line, Zoom call questions so we can easily search
for them because we get hundreds of emails literally a day. All right, thank you very much for
participating. We'll get this recording on YouTube and on the Facebook page. Appreciate all of you.
Love you all. Thank you. Thank you so much. Bye bye. Bye bye.